Sometimes, a movie's production just goes
so off the rails that the most humane thing
the filmmakers can do is to pull the plug.
These are some previously-announced and greatly-anticipated
movies that reached the end of the line in
2019.
Over the course of nearly 20 years, the X-Men
movie franchise placed its ensemble cast of
mutants in different points across various
timelines.
Wolverine was the first character to spin
off into his own sub-franchise, with X-Men
Origins: Wolverine, The Wolverine, and Logan.
For years, Fox tried to get more standalone
mutant movies off the ground, starting with
a proposed Origins follow-up focusing on Magneto,
though this project was eventually reworked
into the ensemble prequel X-Men: First Class.
The other solo X-movie that's come close to
being a reality is one about Remy LeBeau,
a.k.a. Gambit, the Louisiana-born, staff-wielding
mutant who's notably adept at throwing explosive
playing cards.
Gambit is a fan favorite, having been a main
character on the '90s Saturday morning X-Men
cartoon.
He even made a brief appearance in X-Men Origins:
Wolverine.
"Are you Remy LeBeau?"
"Do I owe you money?"
"No."
"Then Remy LeBeau I am."
Fox stacked the deck for the film's chances
by casting likable, bankable Channing Tatum
in the title role.
But the studio just couldn't get this movie
into play thanks to a seemingly never-ending
search for the right director to helm it.
Gambit had been shuffled around a couple of
2019 release dates, but the ongoing director
search left its viability in question.
As 2019 began, Fox had Gambit scheduled for
release in March 2020, despite not having
a director actively attached.
Then Disney acquired Fox, throwing the smaller
studio's whole slate of projects into disarray.
In May 2019, the new bosses moved around the
release dates for a bunch of movies, including
Gambit.
The Tatum vehicle went from a March 2020 release
to… currently nothing, disappearing from
the schedule.
The enduring Star Trek big-screen franchise
flew high for decades.
After focusing on the characters from the
original 1960s TV series, the movies shifted
focus to the world of Star Trek: The Next
Generation, ultimately sputtering out when
the 2002 entry Star Trek: Nemesis grossed
$43 million, the worst-ever showing for a
Trek movie.
It took the visionary sci-fi mind of J.J.
Abrams to revive Star Trek movies for a new
generation, reviving well-known, old-school
characters like Kirk and Spock to create three
fun and contemporary blockbusters: Star Trek,
Star Trek Into Darkness, and Star Trek Beyond.
That last one earned $158 million in the summer
of 2016, enough to merit a fourth entry.
Paramount announced the project at CinemaCon
2018, with S.J.
Clarkson attached to direct.
Zachary Quinto was reportedly up to reprise
his role as Spock, and Chris Hemsworth may
have returned, too, having played Captain
Kirk's father George in 2009's Star Trek.
Not immediately on board, however, was Chris
Pine, the guy that plays the fairly important
role of Captain Kirk.
Pine and Paramount couldn't come to an agreement
on a contract, and the same issue occurred
when trying to sign Hemsworth.
The studio ultimately canceled the entire
movie.
Amidst the 21st-century zombie craze that
gave us The Walking Dead and Pride and Prejudice
and Zombies came World War Z.
Based on the novel by Max Brooks, the movie
starred Brad Pitt as a globe-trekking, military-aligned
hero trying to stop the zombie hordes running
all over the world with their insatiable lust
for flesh.
The film ended with a hopeful-ish ending,
and it grossed a whopping $202 million at
the North American box office, ensuring a
sequel.
World War Z 2 seemed more promising than other
unnecessary sequels, if only because Seven
and Fight Club director David Fincher was
reportedly on board to direct.
There were vague rumors of a 2019 release
date, and according to The Playlist, Paramount
did everything it could to get the ball rolling
— but it never officially gave the thing
the green light.
Everything fell apart, and as of February
2019, World War Z had crawled back into the
grave.
Sequels and prequels are common movie conceits
— but crossover movies?
Not so much.
The most prominent modern mash-up of two established
properties on the big screen is probably Alien
vs. Predator.
Sony hoped to pull off a face-off of its own
with two of its hit comedy brands, Men in
Black and Jump Street.
News of this proposed film hit the streets
via the 2014 Sony hack.
In one leaked document, studio co-chair Amy
Pascal floated the idea, and in an email,
Jump Street's Jonah Hill called the idea,
quote, "clean and rad and powerful."
Sony continued to develop the idea, and at
CinemaCon 2016 announced that the film would
be titled MIB 23, and that James Bobin would
direct.
But just a few months later, Hill seemed to
find the project neither rad nor powerful.
He told the Toronto Sun:
"I doubt that movie will get made.
The Jump Street films were so fun to make
and the whole joke of them was they were making
fun of remakes and sequels and reboots and
then now it's become a giant sequel, reboot."
In January 2019, MIB producer Walter Parkes
admitted it was all over, telling Empire,
quote, "We gave it a shot."
He went on to explain that the whole thing
turned out to be a, quote, "impossible match-up."
While Disney-owned Marvel proceeded full steam
ahead with its Marvel Cinematic Universe,
Sony remained determined to hold on to their
movie rights to Spider-Man.
The MCU solo Spidey stories starring Tom Holland
are co-productions between Sony and Marvel,
but Sony has also been focusing on spin-offs
centered primarily around offshoot characters
in Spider-Man's corner of the Marvel Universe.
Among those films are the Oscar-winning animated
feature Into the Spider-Verse, the hit Venom
starring Tom Hardy, and the upcoming Morbius
— with Jared Leto portraying the "Living
Vampire" — whatever the heck that is.
There was also a proposed endeavor called
Silver & Black.
That film would showcase the adventures of
not one but two Spider-Man side characters:
mercenary Silver Sable and cat burglar Black
Cat.
"You look good.
Been working out?"
"No.
I mean — you know, a little…"
In May 2017, Sony signed up Gina Prince-Bythewood
to direct, and charged ahead for a February
2019 release date.
That changed in June 2018, when the studio
altered its theatrical debut date to… no
date at all.
There had been a few problems along the way,
primarily that shooting hadn't yet begun.
One of the main problems, reportedly, was
that the director didn't like the shooting
script.
No screenplay and no release date usually
imply a movie is dead, but that's not exactly
the case here.
Shortly after Silver & Black lost its street
date, Sony announced that it would instead
make two separate movies: one Silver, one
Black.
Hey — the more the merrier, right?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.